what is this are you ready yeah alright
Cheers
just straight ice cream with a hint of
vodka you can't really taste it but it's
there just tastes like I'm on vacation
in Hawaii it tastes like a fiesta so I
like I think it's up a margarita mmm
these are my two favorite things
it feels like I'm taking it off
I just don't know what it is that might
have whiskey in it vodkas and this and
rama's and this really I was thinking
rum was in this cuz rums like a sweeter
just alcohol in general darn it I was
all wrong doesn't taste like tequila
it's so light we're both over the age of
21 this is tequila oh I kind of tasted
in this one this little room right maybe
or anything but my dad might be like
whiskey I don't know can I get drunk
from this I could eat so much of this
I'm gonna say it's some type of fruity
white girl alcohol so like some type of
fruity vodka let's just go with that
there's not the keel in this rum and
vodka like this is Bailey's shocking
shocking it was delicious
it smells like a shot time I think I
already know it's in that one
I'm gonna guess I think that one's like
a poor handy yeah I was gonna say
bourbon he's maybe whiskey yeah so good
I can't tell if I filled Buster like
brain freeze that smells like vodka that
smells like regret oh yeah this smells
like college that's probably like vodka
hey I feel like I would know if it was
vodka
I feel like warm inside even though it's
cold how much would I have to eat to get
drunk though this is the ultimate
breakup food because yeah oh oh my god
you just like pour more alcohol in it
and you just keep going start crying oh
I love it
Oh